estrella les textes de confiture antinomiens dans OC
copa la la illaha disparais toi Luis
nepali shoma di guardare tu sais doc
aujourd'hui ne pas nos coups je suis dit terme que les
femmes tirent
j'adore jouer à Lone Ranger c'est comme
le rêve de chaque enfant dont j'ai embrassé le
personnage  John Reed et il l'ont fait si
magnifiquement la première fois que j'ai mis le
masque et je le mets juste en pensant
comme ça très cool à voir Devon
fantage soutenant les acteurs de la télévision pour la
justice c'est un bon ashesh devenir plus
averti Johnny est un tel  merveilleux acteur
et il crée toujours des
personnages intéressants jo harlow a construit le maquillage
et il est venu a pris des photos a pris
ces photos à Jerry Bruckheimer
Johnny l'a montré à Jerry et Jerry était
un vice c'est génial non qui a dit c'est
moi hein c'est moi il est brillant  il est juste
incomparable vous mettez ces deux gars
ensemble contre des méchants très vicieux
vous vous habillez comme vous les gens
vous gardez une vie active
je pense que la dernière personne que vous voulez trouver
dans les ruelles sombres butch Cavendish  il est
certainement comme un gars délicieusement diabolique
le film serait le même sans certains
personnages féminins Annette Rebecca Reed
a grandi avec un ranger solitaire et elle
se fait kidnapper par des méchants et ça a
aspiré le Lone Ranger et Tonto pour la
sauver c'est un VIP sur nous  'est définitivement comment
je bas Carter, s'il vous plaît, lisez que votre
sheshine équivaut à un bisque, on ne m'a
pas vraiment proposé de jouer un
chèque de madame du sud à pattes de cheville comme
Twitty vide, vous ne voulez pas jouer avec le
rouge,
je pense que ça va être  une course folle si vous
voulez voir quelque chose d'aussi
divertissant et amusant que des pirates vous aviez
le ranger solitaire maintenant
ah
vous